I put these instructions up earlier so
if you were here you might already know
I run into problems okay or you just
don't want to admit but that's fine okay
who who is I got the repo and the
content environment so they're good to
go
okay I would say this is under half
that's actually better than I expected
to go on there so I think we'll just
we'll just go with it and we won't waste
too much time
you can if you can't download it you
could just follow the notebook online so
if you go to the repo you can click
there and there's enough instructions
but you can just scroll through if any
of you have like if you really want
follow along having specific problem
then maybe a yeah just like stick your
hand up yeah I'm actually the
technically thank you kill do the smart
might problems if you're on Windows by
the way I don't have much knowledge for
of that alright so the way it's laid out
is that if if it's quite simple and
you're already a complete pro with like
pandas for example because now you went
to country pandas whatever it was this
morning then you can just run ahead to
the notebook that's fine and we'll kind
of do you know what a squadron would do
and go at the speed of the slowest man
and it said the slowest person in the
room and feel free to like run ahead and
then there's sort of an advanced
notebook and you can fiddle around with
some of the data I've given you like a
large data set to play with so if any of
you get bored and you want to do some
analysis on that then we could feedback
at the end and you can tell us if you
found something I didn't really have
time to fully go through that so there
could be something interesting so I'm
going to get rid of this now is that
right okay everyone okay cool so who who
already knows
pandas pretty well okay nice so we might
actually blow through the first part and
scikit-learn
okay reasonably good and sort of like
some rudimentary machine learning theory
cross-validation training testing says
it's kind of thing okay nice and NLP
let's try that one okay so this is good
so some of them might be new for some
views that might not be
okay we'll see we'll see how we do I'm
just going to grab the repo I wanted to
make sure I do it fresh so the world at
the same point yeah no problem
so actually you can follow along what
I'm doing here I'm going to do the exact
same thing oh yeah I was going to say
I'm going to do the same thing here so
you can follow along here alright can
anyone read this bigger who else
is this a sequel replacement whoever
just asked that it's not a suitable oh
if you want a floater I say alright
okay so you're just going to go into
here and then if all goes well cut the
end creator it's going to install your
your environment for you
okay well it's going I'll just talk lis
what we're going to do we're gonna do
some pandas we're going to load up some
data so I've labeled some data for you
and this is something I got from a news
API you can go to news API to org it's
free to use and it's sort of like a live
stream of news from various sources you
don't get the full content you get the
title and a sort of summary sentence so
we'll have a look at that and there are
some instructions in the repo if you
wanted to grab your own API key and you
could get the date yourself so I scraped
it for a few weeks
and then some point while watching TV or
something I just went through and
labeled it all so I've done the hard
graft for you so no complain at the
labels are poor alright so the starting
point is that you load the tutorial
notebook probably a few people are
already at that point
everybody here this looks familiar
you've already seen on your screen okay
cool I could slice everyone so I clear
at the back you can see the code okay to
be honest there's not much code to
fiddle so the idea that we're just going
to execute stuff you could fiddle with
some of the cells to as much as you like
but the main content is already all
there so you can just shift enter and
we'll work down together but if you have
any questions any point just stop me and
we'll go whatever pace you guys want to
go we can skip some sections we can go
over things time and time again so
please interrupt I just going to get
probably incredibly boring I just
watching the a shift enter on this okay
so that the series should already be
there so if you load the first couple
will use pandas to load up the CSV so
since I know we can always think of this
as from sort of client perspective or if
we were doing this for for someone to
avoid in some sort of service you're
very often a given a CSV particularly if
you know if they're not that technically
minded you might even get an excel file
you have to dump yourself but that means
it's going to be in a tabular format and
pandas is of course the way to go this
uses objects to represent everything as
tables and it's pretty great so what
you've got here each line is an article
it has an author it has a title and a
published out date which apparently is
sometimes not there and then a label so
a1 means its clickbait or I determined
that it was clickbait and a zero is news
it was actually quite hard
I was labeling some Daily Mail articles
and it's like do I count you know
sometimes I thought there's definitely
clickbait later that's it feel like news
but for some people I don't know like
someone having a toned stomach on a
catwalk is like actually relevant news
for them maybe so I had to refrain from
saying that like Kim Kardashian news was
clickbait there's apparently relevance
so you might debate what I've done it I
don't know
okay so DF dealt head just give us a
quick overview of the data that's a
really good place to start when we've
been handed a CSV you know and let's go
down we can just have a look
example so this the type of their I mean
this is textbook clickbait this is such
poor English literally just nineteen
pictures that prove edge holds a
ridiculously Q so this is exactly the
kind of stuff we don't want to see this
is prime clickbait material so in case
you had any doubt what clickbait was
coming into this hopefully does this
kind of this sort of thing you've seen
on Facebook or social media
you kind of know now what we're talking
about not that you ever needed
convincing of their cuteness TBH so
there you go so we'll do some really
quick panda stuff and I'll go through
the sky thing most people said they've
all use pandas right so we can grab the
label column and we can just be value
count so we can see we have eight
hundred and eight articles than in news
and 557 data clickbait it's actually
quite nice because we're easing the even
distribution of labels which is going to
make things easier for us going forward
now the thing is with pandas is that you
have there's quite a lot of
functionality but I find that no you
just have to kind of keep using it to
eventually learn whether the
functionality is and so much of it sort
of changed together so I find like
eventually when advertising these really
long lines yeah yeah thanks Andres how's
that good okay
so similarly we could get the author
field and we can figure out how many non
values we have and you can also a plot
again I think that was in one of the
workshops this morning or maybe most of
you already know so you can think of it
step by step we grab the author column
we recount or we basically if it author
is no there'll be a walnut like to be a
zero and then we just count the number
of two or focuses there are and then you
just called plot on it so we get a
horizontal bar chart that shows how many
we know and how many were with false
right so there's not much information
there but I just want to give an example
of chaining these calls together and
some floss in something else we can do
is we can apply functions so here the
description column each entry is just a
string right and so we can apply length
to that and it will just tell us the
length of the string so if I remove this
here so that's the number of characters
for the description string for each
article and if you do mean we'll just
get the average length so we can see
okay that's the average length or the
average number of characters in the
description string okay it we're kind of
getting some insights there now so you
know if you can imagine if this words
big data if this was a huge database of
querying you already have a sort of
rough idea of what a deck looks like
from a really high level so from this we
can see okay so description is probably
just a sentence or so telling us a
little bit about the article of course I
cheated I already know exactly what that
string is and then here I've done the
same line that after I've so I've
grabbed the descriptions I computed
their length and all I've done is I've
added this group by and so what this
does is we have this column which has
the length of every field and we're just
going to split the hour into two columns
based on whether they're clickbait or
not and then we just compute the mean of
each of those and now we start seeing
something quite interesting so we can
see that the descriptions for the news
articles are on average longer than the
clickbait ones which is kind of right
this would sort of start of journalism
you get right it'll be pull something
from the Financial Times
probably that sort of leading sentence
is going to be quite convoluted whereas
you know BuzzFeed might say ridiculously
cute tbh
so I think that I think that makes some
sense okay I'm going to skip over this
and something up is really cool we can
be familiar with the numpy is that it
also does broadcasting so you can just
add two columns together and you can eat
so here I'm going to grab all the
descriptions I'm going to add space and
then add the title and so you can sort
of really quickly build a or you could
but you can't quite see actually that's
the full content so I've created a new
column called full content which we just
concatenated this string in the
description right there we go trust no
man trust my brand so we to be put them
together and later on we'll use that but
I just think this is really nice in
pandas that you can just stick these two
things together yes yes so you're
probably more familiar with the pandas
format where you like group the frame
mm-hmm yeah so you can also you can call
group by with any service as long as
it's the same length you can have an
indicator and so in this case we
actually pass it the labels so blue the
labels column is the same length as
though that sort of length of the
description if you imagine yeah so it's
like an indicator and so it bins it
based based on that and that's actually
I actually figured out whilst doing this
workshop because often you if you group
by and then apply it's going to do
something slightly different to doing
the other way around
otherwise you kind of have to make an
intermediate column at some point but
yeah okay good question I recently
discovered it and actually found a
really helpful since there yeah you can
use grew by with any arbitrary thing all
right I put it I thought we'd go slower
up to this point that I think
everybody's following so I put it in to
remind me to stop and take some
questions so it everybody clear so far
nobody's outrageously lost okay good
let's do something more interesting so I
just thought I'd go into some
scikit-learn terminology before we get
fully stuck in so a transformer is a
kind of function where in one end
take some data and then it applies a
manipulation to it and spits data out in
like another shape or another format out
the other side so that's it and usually
they have a fit method so when we fit a
transformer then it basically looks at
all the data we have available and
figures that you know how it's going to
transform our data there's some
parameterization happening they'll
become clearer when we look at a
specific transformer in a minute and
then you have a transform function so
once it's figured out how it's going to
transform your data in a useful way then
we can feed it any data in there and it
will transform it into the same output
if neither say that's writing a lot of
code and you'll see that in a sec and
then a classifier I'm sure if you're
familiar with basic machine learning
terminology then the idea is that we
take a sample say we look at an article
and we just want to put it in one of a
number of bins and we want to do that
algorithmically so in this case the two
bins are clickbait or news click pay or
not click thing so that's all that's
going to do and then a pipeline is a
really nice abstraction the scikit-learn
provides and they provide the whole
interface to this and you can string
together sort of blocks of Transformers
in a row and then put a classifier on
the end and they're brilliant because
what you can do is you can have this
reproducible pipe that's in one object
and you can always put the data in the
same shape in one end and you'll get a
prediction out of the other to offer and
someone gives you some data and you have
to do lots of transformations right
where you need to merge stuff together
and what you can do is you can save all
of those transformations in kind of
reproducible steps so you know someone
always gives me a CSV that looks like
this and it has these columns and then I
turn it into this sort of numerical data
and then I manipulate it this way and
then in the end my classifier and so
it's kind of a you have a recognizable
input and output and you don't have to
think about those kind of weird
intermediate stages that that's the
benefit so let's talk about a
transformer when we have text data and
this is where if you're an NLP guy this
is your turn to be bored or you know if
you really know this but our class for
ism isn't going to be able to work with
raw text data it's not that useful so
what we need to do is turn that text
somehow into some numerical data that we
can use for our classifier and the
typical way to do that is the bag of
words model and it's very very simple so
you imagine you have a sentence you chop
it up into words which are sometimes
called tokens the reason for that is
that punctuation can
to be a token so token could be and the
Craig or it could be a comma exclamation
mark
so we be sparse tensed up into a bunch
of tokens and then you just count how
many of each one there is and that's
your data so in this case we have
literally just a really really cute dogs
would be transformed into this right so
cute appears once dogs appears once just
once and really twice the downside is
that we lose all of the there's no
information on how the words order
together it's just you just notice all
frequencies or how commonly the words
appear or if they don't appear at all so
you kind of lose there any semantic
reasoning that's in there and you also
lose the order in which is a shame but
it's very simple to use and the other
important thing we're going to do is
assign a numerical ID to each word and
this is called the vocabulary so all we
do is when we fit this transformer that
we're going to use its called a
vectorizer because it turns your text
into a vector when we call fit it looks
at all of the words that that we have in
our data and order does is assign a
unique or the token assigns a unique ID
to every single one of those so that in
future you just say okay and is ID 53
and it appears three times so you're
going to have a vector number 53 which
correspond to and f3 will appear that
sort of makes sense so we end up with
words going in and actually the output
maybe I could have made this clearer is
B two columns so you end up with a
vector with indices down here and then
the number of times that those words
appear right so there's pierre-luc
killing the Americal so we do it here
and it's all in scikit-learn so if you
if you run the cells with me we'll
create a vector either this is a called
a count vectorizer and i'm just going to
fit for clarity this sentence we looked
at earlier and then i'm going to print
out the vocabulary write this in the
vectorizer and you can see we've got a
dictionary and so for every single word
that we've seen each one has a unique ID
so now we stop thinking of words in a
textual sense and we start thinking of
them as tokens with just a numerical
number which makes it kind of difficult
to introspect later but it's this is how
the algorithms going to handle our
information and so what we can then do
is we
can transform a new sentence based on
this vocabulary we've learned so I could
do literally five foot yeah five cats
okay so do you see what happens has
happened here is that the vocabulary is
fixed on what you fit it to so each one
of these elements here is so this is
literally which is at number three so
zero one two three this corresponds to
literally and it appeared once but five
in cats was never in our original
vocabulary okay so we're limited by the
training data which makes complete sense
so this is a very contrived example but
really you would have like a big corpus
of documents and you'd feed them in and
you'd learn all the words in there but
then if you send your classifier into
the wild as I often end up saying and it
sees some word that it's never seen
before then it has it has no reason to
base any predictions on that so they
just ignored okay so your vocabulary is
fixed based on what you've seen in your
training data okay I think I just did
the same thing here right yeah also a
good reason to use Python three that
Unicode is fully supported so you can
train on emojis I'm pretty sure so I
could learn users all the way through so
an emoji can be a feature that's
completely fine and so I just give an
example here it's ignored maybe we
should have trained on it I don't know
can you do that let's try hmm I think
maybe it's because so this vectorizer
if you're already you know as it is I'm
following on this is good no one's like
really lost
okay I see lots of nodding lots of money
yeah
I was a fit oh yeah it's good point
let's try that maybe that was it
hmm no I think it's because so let's
remember in Jupiter you can always put a
question mark after a method or an
object to tell you about it the reason
is the tokenization so how we turn a
string into a bunch of individual tokens
is based on this reg X and if you're a
reggae X Pro you'll see that that's not
going to capture Unicode escape
characters
it just looks forward characters but you
can actually write this however you want
so you could pass in your own tokenizer
or you could use I think has a talking
Jensen earlier so they have their own
tokenizer functions and so you could
even use something from another package
and use it like that that's perfectly
fine as long as it takes a string in and
spits an array out
so there it is so that's why the Unicode
doesn't work sorry about that I was
actually quite excited to train on an
emoji bit another time all right let's
go into classification what time do we
finish three thirty ten parts for my
goodness we slow down I mean there's
lots of material to come we'll just
we'll make it up at some point and maybe
you won't notice the transition when
that happens I don't know so let's go
into a bit of detail on the the
classifier so we can use a support
vector machine because very simple and
it's faster trained and we can
introspect it later so here's a textbook
classification tart and we'll always try
and think of this in terms of words an
LP and the clickbait problem so that we
don't lose the context so you can
imagine that imagine our vocabulary is
just two words so and the sentence is
always just made of cat and dog so
everyone's talking cat dog or cat dog
cat cat and so when we put through that
vectorizer that output is just a number
of cats and the number of dogs that
appeared in the sentence in the document
and so you can imagine we could plot
them just like this can you see it in
the mountains a bit small a point so you
can imagine you know if there's a lot of
dogs on this axis and not many cats to
end up here right if you have a few dogs
and loads of cats you sort of
here if you have lots of dogs and cats
and you end up in this corner and so the
idea is that you have in this space and
sort of clusters so I suppose giving
example I've just said I guess these
would be like animal lovers they're
always talking about cats and dogs and
down here they're not really talking
about either maybe I should have split
it another way - you had the dog people
who love dogs and love cats but there
you go so these people say cats and dogs
a lot and these people don't like cats
and dogs and so I've labeled the two
classes so we can imagine that this is
sort of like click bait or lock click
bait it's a very simple example but the
concepts are the same as you go to
multiple words so in this case we just
have two and what we want to do is we
want to find this separating line we
want to find optimally find a line that
describes the split in our data and the
reason we want that is because later on
if I come along with a sentence that has
I don't know this many dogs and this
many cats this isn't a sample we've seen
before but we know that because it lies
on this side of the line that it belongs
to this class it turns out I love
animals yeah so I mean it could be any
class but yet for example of this little
B clickbait and this could not be
clickbait yes that's the idea so then if
a new article comes in we just figure
out which side of this line to the lie
on and so the idea of classifiers we
just want to learn where that line is
that's all in real life we have a huge
number of words it sings by the size of
it English vocabulary so it's not 2d so
you have this very high dimensional
space and rather than finding a line
you're looking for this optimum
hyperplane all right if you prefer
mathematical speak that's what we're
looking for notes as well is that we
don't have to have what's called
linearly separable data so you don't
need your samples to be completely on
our side of the line that the SVM
optimizes itself to find a sort of ideal
minimum and we can we can actually
control that in some way which we'll see
later right is that clear and one's
clear on classification great moving
forward again so I could learn already
has that would you believe it's almost
as if we basis on cycle and
functionality scikit-learn has the SVC
and so here I've just done
we're really doing this in a simple way
so you can see the underlying mechanics
and I was going to show you that
interface it'd be great you guys really
understand what's going on under the
hood so here I have one two three four
five six samples right so this might be
the output of our vectorizer we had six
sentences and in the first case there
was one cat and six dogs they were the
words in it in the second case there was
one cat and four dogs and so on so this
is our vectorized text data okay and
then I've just assigned a label so let's
say this is clickbait clickbait
clickbait and these three arm okay so if
you execute that I wrote a little script
just to plot it so okay this looks like
what we had before right but now you can
see it with some real numbers so we have
some samples down here so this imagine
this x-axis with dogs again so these
people are talking about dogs much more
than they are cats and people cats much
more than they are dogs does that make
sense so we see two very clear
communities of the cat lovers and the
dog lover and we want to find the
separating line between those optimally
and I thought the SVM does so all we
have to do is go to our SVC support
vector classifier object and we just
call fit with our words and their
individual labels and you can just plot
that here and that's what it did for us
so I figured that out itself and now
we've reduced all of this data to just
this single line you know if you show
this to someone you wouldn't even have
to show them these points you just say
this is how we separate the dog lovers
from the cat lovers so if someone comes
in and they mention cats this many times
and dogs this many times we know they're
more on the dog side and the cat side
circlet okay cool
okay yeah so it does still handle that
case and the way it does that is so the
first thing the SVM looks for is to
maximize so you define a thing called a
margin which is the distance between
your line and the sort of opposing
classes so of course you want that to be
as fat as possible because the wide
inner margin is the further you are from
the two so that makes sense here when
they are linearly separable but you
basically penalize it I know are you a
mathematician Internet
okay so if you are it's like a Lagrange
multiplier problem so that means you
basically make that as wide as possible
you choose the line so this margin is
massive but if stuff crosses over then
it kind of gets penalized you have a
score function of some sort and that
score goes down the further if you ship
this little over here you're going to
have like two lines across until the
score is really poor and so it will kind
of move around and a trade-off between
making that margin as wide as possible
and misclassifying there's a parameter
we can choose to choose like which one
of those we prefer no it will always put
one there so yeah well yes absolutely
and that's why actually it's workers
just put your data first
I mean if it's 2d you can if it's 10,000
dimensional you're gonna have a hard
time yeah
but yeah this was a really good point I
always try and visualize your data there
was a really good talk actually since we
have time I will just quick did anyone
see that it was it was maybe someone REM
as the website was on they showed this
2d plot and it had all sorts of
different shapes on of dates like there
was two classes and it showed the
variants on one axis and the variants on
the other and sort of in all cases you
had yeah so someone has seen it I think
maybe in PI data tweeted about this it's
at the one oh yes that's the paper from
the 70s and
yes yes that is the one you go look I
can get it right here I think this is
actually worth the the detour because
okay that makes me sign in what was the
name
OMP
oh that ans Co NPA and I think it with
these guys who came with a cool
animation for it is it maybe it's the
same one okay let's destroy I did not
think I'd be going on Wikipedia during
this workshop okay
yeah it's bit also desk one okay so I
just think based on the commenter we
just made this is really worth looking
into
so look at this so this is data
distribution in different ways and okay
this isn't the full effect but I'm not
going to bother going much further but
they basically show that the mean of the
X and the y data as well as the variance
in X and the y coordinate and the
correlation is the same for three
decimal places for all of these pictures
right so the main message is that you
shouldn't rely on the sort of numbers on
accurate statistics all the time so
definitely always sanity check
you think you might think okay there's
obviously a clear correlation here and
you just end up you have a dinosaur face
and somebody trolled you so I don't know
I think this is really insightful and
I've got a hold an opportunity to share
except on it to tell tell some some
people about it yeah
oh I see okay yes there are ways to look
into it
in particular you have there's a
probabilistic version of the support
vector machine as well and it'll
basically show that there's a very poor
probability that this is a good fit you
can look at the size of that margin and
things like that so yeah plot your data
that's important and of course it's
10,000 dimensional that's an open
question and if any of you have some
cool ideas on how you can do that I'd
definitely be willing to hear how it's
done and today you go okay that was a
very nice segue more of those please
okay so we we found our line let's go
back to where we were
we found this line and so now imagine we
see two novel samples so we've been
shown to word counts samples that we
haven't seen before you can go up we
haven't seen three and one and two and
four before and then it will say okay
this first person was a dog lover and a
second person was a cat lover example
clear what classify doubts why we do it
and how it works with the vectorized
text data all right so you see that was
all in two separate steps and was a
little bit convoluted okay I'm not gonna
go through this now but if you want to
sort of scroll through the notebook
yourself you can learn a little bit more
about how the pipeline works but it's
just important to note that this
pipeline object contains your
transformer so that vectorizer and the
classifier all in one but all you have
to do is stick your training data and
labels in one end the pandas dataframe
and it will train it so it will figure
out that line and it will work out the
vocabulary for you and later on all we
do is pass into new novel features that
we would like to classify some new
documents we'd like to see again just in
the format that they are in the CSV file
and then it's going to spit out labels
so this is the benefit of the pipeline
is that you have this fixed so we've
already decided on the structure of this
it's fixed and all we have to do is CSV
in one end well once it's been loaded
this pandas but seriously on one end and
they without the other end it's that
simple which is great for your non
techie colleagues who would like to sort
of play around with it a bit but don't
see too much code this is this is handy
and the way you define that is also
incredibly easy you just have a tuple of
tuples
so this is a name of the step in the
pipeline and that's completely arbitrary
if you could call it classifier optimum
line finder you could it could whatever
you wanted I've got my vectorizer and I
just created a new count vector either
and then a classifier and they new
classifier all right
and then all we do is import pipeline
from scikit-learn with the steps and
that's it it's that simple so that's a
cyclic Lam pipeline that has the
vectorizer
and a classifier after it any questions
about the pipeline how it works anything
like that nope
you would just want to see the real data
yeah let's do that yep yes yeah so there
can be also transforms with one
classifier at the end however I think
just like it learn has some like
majority voting classifiers they take it
as an input a sort of bunch of votes for
labels and at the output produces over
an aggregated label and as its
parameters it can take more classifiers
so does that make sense
we don't have anything to draw on okay
but you can imagine you have transformer
transformer transformer then the input
could go into ten classifiers and then
you end up with the last classifier
being a voting system so they all vote
and whoever those are the most times so
yeah it's possible but I didn't show it
but the last step should always be some
kind of classifier all right anything
else no good so let's just talk a little
bit about and again I don't Apache lies
anyone but I think it's a really
important point if you don't know
already and this is some really basic
machine learning discipline that we
should follow when we're given some
training data you should always take a
batch of that which you're going to look
at and you're going to use the improve
your model and a bunch of it you're
going to use at the end the sanity check
everything and we call this an
out-of-sample or testing data and my
supervisor must told me that he just
puts it on like a USB stick and the
leader murmurs computer and locks in a
drawer which i think is really extreme
but this is basically the sort of level
of discipline you should show so you
should you could create your testing
data and you lock that away and you sort
of build your models and play with your
models and test
you should look at that and then at the
end of the day or at the end of the
project you can go and check how what we
do on data that you've never seen before
and that sort of as close as possible
you get the performance you might see in
production and so you're not gonna put
it in production and get wild surprises
I mean that's so common even you know
often we need to move fast in a company
and we don't have time to follow this if
you're really thinking about from the
start it's possible because you really
want to minimize the surprises you get
between training performance and
production performance so do that and so
I could learn would you believe it
offers a way to do it ok so this is just
called train test split and so what I'm
doing is passing B F if you remember
that's a poor variable name then we're
going to stick with it this is just the
data set we originally started with the
CSV and then we specify that 70% of that
we want the training so we're going to
spit it our data frame into two separate
data frames one is 70 ton of examples
one is 30% we also give a random state
so this is it's also going to do some
random shuffling of the rows the reason
being is that often you have sort of
like in this case it's actually true
all of the clickbait is in one chunk and
all of the news of one chunk so if you
sliced it that way your training data is
going to be like all clickbait for
example so it's going to be terrible so
if shuffles up your data to make sure
you have an even distribution of the
classes and then it splits it and that's
shuffling we kind of want to be
deterministic so if at the end of this
we find out where our accuracy is 80%
and then we give someone this notebook
because it's random they might end up
with a different statistic and they're
like well okay I actually found out was
75 so I'm not 80 so all the how could
you do but you can set a random state
and say always start the random number
generator with this seed so although
it's random every time you run the cell
you'll get the same as I'll back ok that
that makes sense I think good and
finally it's often quite a good idea to
use stratification so what this does is
if you imagine you shuffle all the rows
there's still a chance that you shuffle
them and you put all the clickbait back
together in one row and all the news
back in one row unlikely but of course
there's a chance the stratification just
ensures that the distribution of classes
in the training and the testing set are
exactly the same so you just tell it
like these are my labels so please just
make sure that my training and testing
has
the same proportion of clickbait in news
in them and then that way again we don't
have a huge surprise when we move to
testing okay so I'm going to run that
and then we can now look at the so the
output of that is one training set and
one testing set
so from here on we're not going to touch
the testing okay remember that and so
here's why training looks like you can
see it shuffled so the index on the left
has changed but otherwise it's mostly
the same all right now I just need to
sort of probably the Fenny of the some
of the news our tools are scrape from al
Jazeera and things I know that we're in
times of political instability so if
there's something shocking I do
apologize but it was just a live stream
that I pulled down okay and until you
can see there if your massive good
approximately a 70 to 30 percent split
of data and so we defined our pipeline
up here if you remember we said that our
first step is going to be one of these
vectorizer now remember these are
untrained so I just created new objects
so all we're saying is our pipeline
consists of this vectorizer and this SVC
we've really said nothing about the
parameters or any data and all we do
it's called pipeline dot fit again as we
did before and we're going to pass it
the titles of all the articles in the
training set and the labels so always
saying is okay here here is the a bunch
of samples and they have a string which
is the title and then we can tell the
classifier if its clickbait or not and
it's going to turn them all into numbers
cast them into the huge high dimensional
space find the optimum hyperplane and
then we have a way of predicting these
samples so we just press shift enter on
that and it's done that is it and so now
we can start predicting things so you
can play around with these as much as
you want today go ten things you need to
do I don't know why did that so tempting
that's that's apparently clickbait you
could try I don't know seriously
hilarious
cats OMG okay it's also clickbait but
you could for example try something like
to do the French election that gives you
zero we could try ok I'll be into French
dog polls if that doesn't change it
so early for Kimmy kay okay okay one
thing I actually found whilst playing
with it is that this is a very strong
indicator of clickbait yeah okay that
slipped it this was really interesting
right if you think about journalism in
general like if you're a good Janet II
would never use this in sort of like
it's there's no information in that it's
like headline this article is going to
blow your mind
like that's not for having be great
journalism so I think this is a very bad
feeling something so if you want to
avoid clickbait just in general don't
pick a choice that has this in it I also
find that you I think it's quite
predicted that's shown your French dog
yeah so that was it works today go the
Financial Times would not address the
reader will say this yeah so the ISO
here so we have to initially so I don't
leave allows it so further up here you
see that in order to find the separating
line we need to know that these are
certain class blue and these ones are
certain class orange if we didn't know
that then we would just have like six
points in this space and we wouldn't
really know where to start drawing any
sort of line I mean if it was an
unsupervised clustering approach which
maybe I haven't made clear is this is
different if this was like a clustering
approach then you wouldn't have to have
labels and it would say well these are
roughly together so they must be
something and these are roughly together
but actually here we're giving it more
info we're explicitly saying these are
clickbait in these aren't code base does
that sound to the question okay cool so
we have to say here's a bunch of samples
and this is and it's whether they're
clickbait or not and where is here these
are new samples that we've just invented
and we we don't know whether they're
clickbait but we would like to know so
that's there's the difference between
there the project it's not clear to
everyone sitting and predicting cool
okay so let's wrote a small script this
actually isn't in scikit-learn but you
can have a look at the
the functions that I wrote and they're
actually quite simple inside so all this
does is it looks inside the SVM and
tries to figure out which words are the
most important so it shows these are the
sort of top words associated with
clickbait so the things that tell us
most that something its clickbait TV vs.
news and actually makes a lot of sense I
was really surprised because the dataset
is relatively small so I've given you
about 1,500 samples just under and if
you think about the size of the English
language I said that before you get end
up with a huge multi-dimensional space
and so 1,500 articles is not that many
to like find exactly box click basis
remember our vocabulary is fixed so
there are all sorts of words that we
could see that we haven't seen before
say for example it thinks 21 is like
really important and that's actually
true you often see numbers going to see
these lists like sighs hilarious
hedgehogs but we I guess we would assume
that 21 should be as predicted as 23 for
example but we haven't seen 23 before so
you can see we need like a lot more
features in order to do something useful
so I was really pleased with the
performance and actually the support
vector machine is actually quite robust
much more than other algorithms to this
really high dimensional space problems
where you have not many samples yep
yes sir it's actually based on their
like coefficient so you can take out the
model like the relative weight of
importance of every single word so what
I do is I just like I get all of the
words that we've learned in the
vocabulary figure out their weight in
the classifier and then I sorted it by
the what is most weighted towards the
positive class and the next class so you
just look for the biggest positive
coefficient and the biggest negative so
there is oh is that so if I do from you
know roughly that Li
okay great
so we can try that mm-hmm so very nice
so I was going to try to quickly fine oh
this is related to the line guys okay
listen let's segue again who's heard of
line okay great so this is nfident nips
and maybe a couple years ago now still
highly relevant despite what was said
this morning in the deep learning
of course lime isn't going to get me
either lime
I've tried this before look at that so
this is really cool and this doesn't
even work where that's called vector
machines this works with arbitrary like
black box models I could be learning
model or something and what this does is
look at this great output we get so this
is great for showing colleagues or
whatever and you can show how productive
you are this so what you do is you you
you have your train classic classifier
like a support vector machine and then
you input into it like a new sample and
it shows you the and it formats all this
formatting for you in the notebook it
shows you specifically which of the
words are contributing to one class or
the other so example here they're trying
to classify between atheism and
Christian I guess based on emails and so
they put this email in and we don't know
if the person or the topic or the
content is a total Christian but it
determines which way as quite
interesting that it looks like having a
dot edu email makes you more likely to
be atheist I leave that open to
interpretation but yeah so that's quite
cool right and see if you want to
introspect the models whether asked you
can go really deep with these kind of
tools they exist but this is a really
also an open research question so I know
if you're looking for a PhD or something
this would be a really cool topic
because it's moving fast and it's really
interesting and I think important for
the field as well okay nice work and
I'll look at Eli five four elephants
another time
that was called the lime lime sorry I
guess this is I I don't know what the
motivation was here if it could have
been topic modeling it could have just
been a classification problem but
teaching any more about this okay it's
just okay so Chad the same as all we're
doing that's the motivation okay thanks
okay okay you can also do multi class
pretty cool let's yeah sorry are the
utils plotting is just something I wrote
that in there in the the repo do you
pull down that's their utils okay I'm
not moving too slow people are getting
bored so Rose you're not following along
this might be a little okay all you're
to turn back to complain I don't blame
you I'll do the same okay so I'm going
to move on in ignorance of how you feel
about the workshop so far and we're
going to keep keep going okay so the
next thing we want to do is we want to
figure out actually how well we've done
so we don't know that yet we've looked
at the features we look at the top words
and actually they've where you filled us
probably with a lot of confidence
because they match our intuition again
really important this comes back to the
plotting that's always at each step
think about what the intuitive answer is
of course an intuitive answers usually
the most important ones they'll get you
high up on the hacker news but you know
you need to be able to breathe in at
least in some way otherwise we start
losing sanity in our models and
confidence if we give this or sell this
to someone as you might be doing I don't
know
so what we do here is what's called
cross-validation and who knows
cross-validation and who's never heard
the word before hmm okay good so we
don't need to go into it so this is
basically a way of getting predictions
out of our classifier without ever
looking in the testing data so we can
get an approximate idea of how well
we're doing without overfitting
so we do that
and I just created again this is the
helper script I wrote it shows the
performance so I passed it the real
labels from our training data and those
that we predicted and we see we get not
bad actually incredibly good 91.8% which
is nice and there is a computer matrix
so this just shows so these are the true
labels on the left and on the horizontal
axis is what we predicted so you know
there are 552 that were news and we
predicted them as news by first thing of
them we got wrong and predicted as
clickbait and vice versa we got most of
the clickbait but a few of them we
actually said work with you so you can
see we're worth just distinguishing news
from clickbait as we are from 2 beta
means
and so we ideally want a strong diagonal
in that matrix and in a multi-class
problem where we have more than just two
things that they could be then you know
it's the same concept this will be
larger and you want high scores on the
diagonal that clear ok good
and it's also a great idea to have a
look at where we went wrong and see if
we can get some insights into what
happened so these ones are all wrong so
you can assume we predicted the opposite
of the real label so only a true
pop-culture nerd will recognize
something ok so this definitely should
have been clickbait so something's going
wrong and again it's probably something
to do with our limited vocabulary
probably we didn't know that nerds was
mentally click babies for example okay
so not much here but do always look at
your misclassified samples to get some
information this is all part of the
model selection process ok so now I
think we're just going to start trying
to improve the model somehow so we till
we got 19% we'll see if we can push it
up a little bit so the first thing and
maybe let's move quickly through this by
instead of training during the last time
I took a pipeline I trained it on the
titles and they're respected labels now
we're going to use title description so
in general this is a good idea we're
giving it more text it should definitely
a better job of predicting and I just
printed the performance again after that
so now we get 90 is that the same okay
yeah cool we we've gained one and a half
percent
so you can't assume that often and this
is I think this is another good lesson
the cheap and dirty approach as I've
some ones her to be called can often get
you a long way towards a decent
performance and then at some point you
have this tale of performance which you
have to a lot of effort to push that way
now of course that's the difference
between the sort of masses and
intellectual property or really high
value but if you're just trying to throw
something together I would say once you
get to like a certain point you can call
it a day and you don't need to keep
pushing and we're seeing that exact
thing here we're going to add a bit of
complexity but we really don't get that
much for it but of course if you're
Google versus Amazon those two percent
make a huge difference something else we
can do is use a tf-idf exit vectorizer
who's heard of tf-idf okay so this has
been a slow workshop the so the can
vectorize I counted how many of the
words appeared in each case in the
tf-idf tf-idf which is term frequency
inverse document frequency okay nice
nice good morning so the tf-idf vector
just Waits those words according to how
rare they are so for example if
something says and a lot at the moment
it something scored is very relevant
just cuz it appears a lot so if you have
the word dog appear twice and and
appears ten times and it's kind of like
oh this must be very much about and but
and is very common in the English
vocabulary and dog is less common so
what we should do is wait that and say
well actually and often appears very
very often so that comes down whereas
dog doesn't appear that often so that
becomes more relevant so that makes
sense cool so we use we just use that
all of done is recreate the pipeline
steps and I've dropped in tf-idf instead
of a count vectorizer
and we squeeze just done there another
percent out of it now I and you can see
we're actually doing a better job at
reducing these misclassifications than
these I think this was twelve before and
something else which the I to live on
the train here this morning the the
vector rises take this kind of
preprocessor function so before you do
that text to numerical data
transformation you can pre-process all
the straight
and you saw before that a one of the
features is 21 and I was saying oil
probably numbers in general or good
feature so what I've done is I've
written this function called mark
integers and it takes a string and
returns a string so that that's all that
you have to write to the preprocessor as
long as it takes one string and spits
one out and I've used reg X substitution
so all I do is search for a set of
numbers in a row integers and then I
replace it with this word int mask and
so so that's so I could do mask integers
456 camels laughing and it sends it to
that advanced cameras laughing okay so
why is it handy because we think that
numbers in general a useful feature so
what we do is we just represent all
numbers as this word in mask or na you
know anything either one
I just don't think in masks would come
up in any of the samples and the idea is
that 17 camels laughing against 15
cameras laughing are really no different
in our concept of like why that is a
useful feature we think it's useful
because our speed put some numbers in a
lot and you know the Daily Mail uses
less so I do that and all I do is I
recreate this vectorizer but I just
passed the preprocessor like that and
again you saw earlier there's so many
interesting options and I definitely
recommend on the train home or whatever
go check out what all of these do and
they're really helpful and they just
save you so much coding often if you
have an idea a kind of function sort of
exists it's like it let's do it already
so we Hey
oh really
so got worse so okay that's interesting
so yeah very nice
so how did you so you extracted the
number out okay cool yeah not very nice
so great I did so the way you went down
but the theory is that BuzzFeed uses odd
numbers okay that's interesting I
actually find if I'm like adjusting the
volume on something I always go to even
so I don't know if it's related to that
or not I don't know okay so that's so
that that's that cool Evon following I
think so good and the final thing we're
going to do is we're going to play with
some high parameters so these are you
can see actually we sort of already used
in a way a high parameter here or
previously we just use the default
settings we created this SVC and the
vectorizer and we don't pass in the
argument but there are things such as
the crushing hammer folio the trade-off
between how much we allow things to
cross over the line in the vectorizer
and we also have various other options I
started that was in the classifier we
also have various options to choose in
the vectorizer
the question is how do we do it and we
do something called a grid search so I'm
just going to recreate this pipeline
again again I'm going to use the default
parameters alright I create the pipeline
and then here I create a dictionary
right so the structure of this is who's
seen this before
okay only a few people okay cool
so the structure of it is these are
basically parameters we want to vary in
the Constructors for objects when we
create the vectorizer and the SVC for
example we don't know whether the mask
integers thing is actually useful on the
end
I mean well okay we do we could run it
once without and once with but how about
if we change other parameters at the
same time and so we might also want to
try odd and even as well as just wanted
replaces numbers and so what we do is we
just we give the name to the key is the
name of the steps remember we name the
steps here let's let's classify and then
the keyword argument for its constructor
so general asked um I created it with
preprocessor equals mask
integers so you just passed that here so
what we're saying is is we want to vary
these parameters in the class size and
what it's going to do is when we fit it
it's going to make a model for every
single combination of all of these
parameters okay so we try you know this
many times this many times this many
times this many different models and
it's going to train them all and tell
you which one of those was the best
there's a bit of a brute force approach
there's no clever optimization going on
you just compute all of these models and
pick the best one and so some things are
varying here is stop words this is sort
of like a whitelist so these are words
note sorry a blacklist
so these are words that you want to
ignore so it's often things like it's
and and the on that informative so we
just want to strip them out and
scikit-learn has a dictionary called
english and that will just remove like
very common English words and things
aren't very useful so we'll try
stripping those out and we'll also try
none I'm going to try my masking
integers and I'm going to try it without
I'm going to vary this parameter C which
we were talking about earlier so this is
just a hydrometer for the classifier and
also the Engram range so this is quite
interesting when we did this
tokenization so you split the words in
two numbers it was just our word basis
but we could also so they're called uni
grams we could also do by grams so we
could chunk blocks of two words and the
idea is that we managed to give some
context to words after that for example
I don't know fall down and down a kind
of like two quite different things so we
can use both and so here we use just uni
grams here is uni grams and by grams and
here just by grams so I'm going to my
detail about it but we'll try it the
pipeline this
sorry yep so the pipeline is just a
combination of the vectorizer and the
classifier you remember we it's just the
sort of larger box containing two
smaller boxes okay maybe I'm avoiding
technical terms too much and just
confusing you I don't know okay okay so
then we just call Fiat the same way so I
created this grid search object from the
pipeline but it behaves very similar to
the pipeline we just call fit on it with
the same data I've passed it at the full
content and the label and now you can
see it actually taken quite a bit of
time and it spits out some debugging
type stuff sorry yes in fact I must have
anticipated your question so there's a
thing called n underscore jobs and it
was like how many calls you want to use
to run it to scikit-learn or D that's
parallelization for you how useful
although I do just want to give a caveat
I want to really complicate the pipeline
and I got a race hazard and it like oh
it all locked so I don't know keep it on
the scikit-learn I'm still in beta right
so keep an eye on their bugs but it does
sometimes a lot but if you set number
jobs to minus one that will use all of
your cos available all right so that
makes it go fast so actually if you
don't say that in my run quest loader
yes sorry it's supposed to want yet so
I've never had problems on that but I've
had it set to minus one in a script and
I deployed it somewhere and it was
horrible so yeah so maybe maybe don't
use in production yet I think it was one
thing we forget it's true of planners as
well is that they're both technically
beta the user base is so big as we think
of them as stable but they things have
no qualms with changing the interface
and not having it being backwards
compatible and either we've all felt a
pain or those developer here and now
they hate me I don't know so yeah I've
definitely felt the pain and it's still
true in scikit-learn so why did I just
execute that again okay we'll wait and
then what we do is we fit the object and
then out of the other side we can just
get out we can look at the best
parameters and the score associated with
it so if you imagine we built this grid
of parameters and every grid point we
trained a new model and then we
look at all the scores and pick the best
one and so let's see what we get okay so
the best value of Si was one there's no
real physical interpretation to that see
value by the way but you do almost
always want to optimize it and find the
best one so I find a good way to just
start at like ten to the minus five and
go up to ten to the five and then you
can hone it down a little bit it turns
out that the by grams were not useful so
you can see that we have you know grams
only what else have you got
oh the preprocessor that sounds our
masks interesting what's useful so it's
said that that's a good a good idea and
it hasn't used stop words which actually
I think isn't surprising probably the
difference between clickbait is actually
a lot in those really small grammatical
uses because we're basically defined
difference between like okay I was going
to bout to say good at good and bad
journalism I don't know they're like two
different styles of writing you know
it's not so much a topic so I really
think those words are important and the
best score we got was 96.5% quite nice
okay so usually this you might be doing
this for several days or something like
this but the idea that we had that
testing data locked away in a drawer and
there's always the standard that you've
over fit to the data so you picked your
models operate perfectly on your
training data and when it goes into the
wild then it's going to perform poorly
so we can do this final sanity check and
see how we do on data that we've never
seen before
okay so what I do is I call pipeline
sorry I could go to a grid search and
ask the best estimator that's just a
helper function which stops you from
like having to recreate the pipeline
with all these best parameters it's
they've already done for you so you grab
it and then what we do is predict on the
testing constant and we see we actually
do really well I was really pleased when
this came up actually I ran a last night
I was happy that could have been a major
embarrassment so it looks like it
generalizes pretty well and actually we
oddly we've done slightly better than we
did on our best training data so that's
quite nice all right any questions no
and how long we do we have to ten past
okay cool let's do that so one feature
of scikit-learn which if you've been use
it for a while you might not be aware of
but I find is like a very overpowered
feature of it is that the pipelines are
pickle herbal so when you train the
pipeline you can save that whole
structure with yep sorry
how can you pickle it you say oh I see
yeah yeah okay so I don't know that much
about the element of it but so yeah you
can so I just use the pickle thing you
think there's a better interface for
doing the pickling okay I didn't know
that so there you go I've just used the
people thing it seems to work just as
well so there are your pickling if
you're not familiar it's just that you
can dump Python data into a file which
is great because you can persist that so
what I've done here is now again here's
some good practice you version your
classifier so look with this version one
the first one we have a built and it's
going to save all of the data and the
parameters and the model you know okay
it's not all that distinct into the way
of saved you can imagine everything that
we've trained this on is kind of chunked
together in one file and so I'll just do
that here and we've and we've dumped it
to a file and so there are lots of
things you can do with it that's the end
of the kind of main part but we do have
more to show it does anyone have any
questions on what we've seen on pickling
on any step of all it's done sorry I
didn't hear which we do it although wait
this might run really slowly now so what
to what happens with the gamma parameter
this is in the classifier right
which one are you referring to here okay
yeah sorry so yeah we're limit yeah so
the full SPC has some more options by
the probability yeah okay good point and
sorry for the confusion but yeah we can
we can chug lots in there and do it out
actually what I've done here so if
anyone who isn't familiar you know if
you understand SVM's but you have knew
this like Adele in space they have
linear SVC which is like a support
vector classifier with a linear kernel
but it would have a more general SVC the
only difference is the numerical method
that's on the back end so if you're
going to use a linear kernel in general
you should use linear SPC but you can
use the normal SPC and specified linear
kernel and it uses a more generic
numerical optimization on the back end
so it has more parameter to fiddle with
more options all right yeah it is it
okay make sense so there's a trade-off
more options let's look out of the end
but I think you can actually use the
probabilities that come out you can use
a probabilistic model on that case and
it but yeah this is a good point okay so
that's that okay that there's two other
things that we can show you and these
are just based on what we might do after
we've saved our classifier and I always
like to think of things again from the
sort of client perspective and so you
think if you're doing this for
intellectual property or something you
can pickle the classifier and you can
hide that behind you know some sort of
function or you can hide it somewhere
into a binary or you could hide it
behind a REST API even and you can kind
of keep the data and the way that you
find everything but you can expose the
predictive power of the model to
something else okay maybe that resonates
with some ideas that you guys have in
mind
hey yeah encrypt it anything you like
so did anybody move on to this already
did someone come up with some like
interesting statistics because it's very
sparse
oh yeah yeah thanks okay so what I did
here this was just starting to fiddle
around with the the prediction so I'll
import pandas and there's another
seriously called all data so in the last
case we didn't have the source available
I just go I want to keep things simple
but now you can play it play with it as
much as you want so we have the VM
source there and so you can see okay
yeah again there's that literally just
nineteen pictures and that we can
actually see it's on BuzzFeed which I'm
sure you guessed but it's that and so we
can import our classifier which is
version
oh no yeah really
what so fire yes ah yes I did it in line
as the rest of you also followed did
anyone for see this happening and so the
reason is as I said I added this on the
train this morning and also you didn't
fully test the rest of it very foolish
but it did make the journey go faster ah
okay oh but it still worked
hope is not okay hasn't run yet all
right so I mean it's not going to work I
get oh we're about to find out so their
dates a little bit messier in this case
so I basically am replacing the
description sites and text columns by
replacing the values that are nan was
jumping around okay it's all something's
breaking so where there's missing values
I just replacing with an empty string
because you know that's at the moment
probably the best way to handle missing
values so that's just tidying up the
data a bit and we care no it goes up
again and
okay I'm not going to use the published
outfield for now it's the same again all
we have to do is we load the classifier
I actually really don't know if this is
going to work now
okay yeah it seems to be working cool so
we just create the predicted labels and
what I've done here is I just assign a
new column to the data frame called
label and so you know so you realize in
this case actually the training dates
containing their so I'm teaching a
little bit but we didn't have the labels
so you can imagine we didn't know the
weather this stuff was clickbait or not
but now we've actually predicted and
here we should actually expect because
these appeared in the training data that
they're going to be correct right but
there are those that weren't in there
okay so what can we do so one thing I
did here oh okay so I get our data frame
I group it by the new source which is
now available to you guys I give the
label out and I sum it so this is the
total number of things that we did
predicted clickbait for each source and
because there's actually very that I
think we have bed any from the plant two
times but loads from the Daily Mail for
example I've also normalized here so I
also group again by the sauce and just
count the number of samples there are
that make sense to get the BuzzFeed and
you just it's like a so we end up
computing the proportion of clickbait
for each one and then I'm going to plot
it on a horizontal bar again and here it
is so BuzzFeed unfortunately is very
quick Beatty I'm actually not completely
familiar with all these then I'm read
the verge is that true is that is that a
good amount of yeah it's about right I
think Mashable I've definitely been told
by them so that's not bad the metro
maybe more than I thought al-jazeera
Nunn Financial Times also known so
actually I the other day and this you
can see here before the water was
finished it would think before I did
those extensions the Financial Times
actually had quite a few apparently
clickbait the articles but I seem to
have removed them so that's actually
quite I'm quite happy with that well
that does ruin the next bit of demo are
going to give you but anyway
so yeah that's that and actually turns
out the TechCrunch it's also quite basic
I think that's actually true yeah you
think that's fair okay
did anyone so that does the end of this
one that I don't try anything else here
did you get some insights no I made it
through advanced notebook I suspect some
of you did you just want bright enough
to gets me interesting at it yeah well I
couldn't so I'm not surprised
yeah so let's do that so the end in case
you guys want to go away and also build
something based on news or you can put
this on your blog or whatever this is
awesome
this is free and you can just sign up
get an API cube there it's a media you
have to give them your email address and
this is a REST API that you can query
and it has look at these all these new
sources available to you you don't get
the full content okay you just get the
title the publish time things like that
but it's nice if you want to show
headlines on your blog or your website
or you want to scrape it like I did for
some machine learning and we found out
actually that the title description is
enough to do some useful stuff so that
that's actually quite cool I think but
because some of these are paid for
services they don't give you the
confident the URL is news API org sorry
you can't see that but there's a name
news API
org and in the so that's the end of the
notebooks in here I've got a folder
called a directory called web service
and if you go in there I built like a
really quick flash gap visually very
unappealing but the functionality is
there so let's just take a look okay
so I've created like a temp device in
HTML that we're going to show in the
browser and then I have this function
now I didn't actually have time to do
exactly what I wanted to do here but you
could put this behind a REST API right
so you could make this a post request or
get requests and I don't know what
actually would be best if you retrieve a
label what's the standard put it but you
know but you can't make go to predict
Lacrosse I'm thinking like nobody know
so it's open I tried to find information
on this I couldn't so
say we make a get request so you or poke
thing that will do with your page so
what you could do is that you could have
a URL and you post adjacent to it with
like your information in and then it
will just spit back a label so this is
really nice if you do want to hide all
of the back ends from somebody you just
want to expose the predictive power to
them then you can put it behind an API
and you send titles to it and it will
just tell you bits clickbait or not so
that's really nice for a web service and
it keeps your front-end alight and your
web server is really light and somewhere
you know if we got on AWS you could have
some scalable stuff and they actually
sort of do that with their lambda
function I don't work for AWS so that's
that all I do is every time and I'm kind
of sticking with the idea that it's
stateless so every time you call this I
like load maybe this add unnecessary but
I load the classifier from scratch and
then I put it come on all right so this
should always return the exact same
thing
of course you could inversion it as well
and you could version your API so you
could say you can query my version 3 API
or you can use the version 1 one and you
can store as metadata and you know these
things would that would build with the
version 1 1 in the version 3 there's all
important for testing later once you've
predicted tens and tens of thousands of
stuff at some point you're going to want
to know like when I deployed version 3
was actually any better when it was in
production so this is really important
to version your classifiers so later on
you can back work where the work you did
was that useful or not clear great so
I've got that and then here I just make
a request to that News API I've given an
API key I check that it's all there and
then here I just add the title and
description together that I get back
from the request and then I grab the
label I see people are clearing out so
they're almost done that's it I think I
can need to export some environment
environmental variables to make this
work first time that's right
I think they spawned for the conference
right so I'm obliged to do this
yeah it should have been in my
environment fun oh it's incorporated
maybe buddy's been imported oh it's not
okay thank you I'm sorry I don't have
the full anaconda distribution just uh
mini combat oh it's that it's working
quick no oh I don't believe it
no actually I do I absolutely believe it
what yeah it's yeah it turns out I was
like what I can't be that one so well
you know people usually say this is a
terrible idea that it seems to work work
great hmm there are some some
motivations myself there or something
all right let's try this
okay
we think it's going to work oh I use it
so okay it's to do with this mask into
just thing I'm just going to quickly get
rid of that you know why if you figure
it out okay so sorry everybody saw their
little anticlimactic but I'm sure you
saw we're going to happen I'm going to
pull down live the articles from the API
predict on them and then serve them up
in not a crucified format but it's there
yeah so let's just get rid of the
pre-process option yes I should have who
just said that I should have created
another version of the classifier very
good but I haven't it's exactly what I
just said don't do for the sake of speed
obviously you've just fixed it yeah well
there you go
it's over we're going we're going to run
without it
so the result is oh so you've got it
somebody causes mayhem all right great
so you've got a better version than I
have from yours nice work actually I
want to see that afterward okay okay so
so all this is is and again I know it's
quite ugly and I was hoping to have
various news outlets here but I've gone
for Daily Mail it's grabbed the titles
live from that news API so these are the
ten most recent articles published on
Daily Mail like really up to the second
or when I loaded the page it's not
responsive on the register you have to
refresh dump data and that it's taken
that sent it to our classifier which we
made in the notebooks and stuff but we
pickled it down and then it's cooled it
it's loaded it predicted and then I just
added is not clickbait or is and it
looks like everything here is not
clickbait maybe that's reasonably sir I
think it is okay what a shame this
should be a mix but correct but this is
something you can do so I think that's
basically the end so if you have any
questions we want to reach me afterwards
then let's do it but otherwise the
coffee queues getting big so
[Applause]
[Music]
you